[Music]
hello everyone
uh in our previous discussions of this
2d elasticity chapter
we had been time and again referring to
this all important
pi harmonic equation so
we had this del 4 phi equal to 0
and in the rectangular cartesian
coordinate system
the expansion of this uh was
like this del 4 phi del x 4
plus twice del 4 pi
del x square del y square plus
l four pi del y four
is equal to zero now when we wish
to go over to uh the solution
of such problems where the rectangular
cartesian coordinate system
is not very convenient rather it is the
polar coordinate system that is the r
theta coordinate system
which is a more natural choice
for the solution of the problem then
what do we do
well to answer that question we could
proceed by two roots
first we could reframe our
entire theory starting from the
kinematics chapter
through the stress chapter material
behavior
as well as all the discussions involved
in 2-d elasticity
that is to say the plane stress
discussions and the plain strain
discussions
in the r theta coordinate system and
then arrive
at the counter part of this by harmonic
equation
in the r theta coordinate system that is
the first root
or we could take a shorter route and
arrive at arrive at the
polar version of this pi harmonic
equation
directly from this rectangular cartesian
coordinate
version so all that you have to do
is to recognize uh
the very well known very well known from
our high school days
uh the relations that
x is equal to r cos theta
and y is equal to r sine theta
if we have these then we we all know
that we have x square plus y square
is equal to r square and
y by x is equal to tan theta
from these two relations uh what we can
do
is convert these derivatives
del del x del del y
in terms of del del r del theta
it's not going to be very straight
forward but we can find out
the the conversions from this x
y system to the r theta system and that
is exactly what we'll do
and for this development what we'll do
is we'll follow
the route that is presented in the
classic book on elasticity
by timoshenko and goodyear okay
so as a first step
you please note that
we can find out
del r del x
from this relation so what we can do is
we differentiate this relation with
respect to
x so what i'm going to write here is
basically the right hand side first and
then the left hand side
so you understand that when i
differentiate this right hand side with
respect to x
this is going to be twice r del r del x
and on the left hand side i'm just going
to get this as twice of x
and this is easily simplified
as x by r and since x is equal to r cos
theta
we we have this del r del x
as cos theta next
in a very similar way uh we can obtain
the del r del y simply by
differentiating this relationship
with respect to y so we have
twice r del r del y
is equal to twice y and that gives us
del r del y is equal to
y by r and y by r from this
relation here is nothing but sine theta
all right next in order to find
the corresponding derivatives uh
or the theta that is to say instead of
del r del x
uh if we want to find out del theta del
x we have to consider this relationship
and for that we'll again differentiate
this relationship with respect to x
first and then with respect to y
so here if we if we differentiate this
with respect to
x what we'll obtain is
minus y by x square
is equal to x square theta
del theta del x all right
and this will give us
del theta del x is equal to
minus y by x square
cos square theta however y is equal to
r sine theta we replace that
and x is equal to r cos theta
so this is r square cos square theta
and we also have a cos square theta here
so this cos square theta cancels with
this cos square theta
and ultimately what we have is minus
sine theta by r
in a similar fashion let us do the
differentiation of this relationship
with respect to y
and what will obtain then is 1 by
x is equal to
x square theta del theta
del y
so that del theta del y is
cos square theta by x
and just replacing x by r cos theta
what we'll obtain is a cos theta
by r so we have
this relationship here
this is our del r del x
just the cos theta we have the
del r del y which is just the sine theta
this is our del theta del x
and this is our del theta del y
all right now why did we do all this
uh why did you find all these
expressions
uh the reason is simple that uh
given any function f of r
and theta uh can we find out
the the derivatives with respect to x
and y and let's see how we can do that
using the chain rule in the next line
in the next page
so what we want to arrive at
is del f del
x but written in terms of the
derivatives with respect to
rn theta so using the chain rule
what we have is del f
del r times del r del x
plus del f del
r theta del theta
del x so here we are proceeding with the
understanding
that this f is a function of r and theta
both in a similar fashion
for del f del y
we have del f del
r del r del y
plus del f del theta
del theta del y so you see in the
previous page
we had already obtained the expressions
for del r del x
del r del y del theta del x and del
theta del y
we can directly use those expressions
here
and given a particular form for this f
or this function f of r and theta we can
easily find out
these these things now
where are we proceeding from here you
see
if we go back to the previous page our
ultimate aim
is to convert this by harmonic equation
the left hand side of this by harmonic
equation
written in terms of the derivatives with
respect to x and y
in terms of the derivatives with respect
to r and theta
so uh so if we have uh so
so you see we we need fourth order
derivatives here
okay so here fourth order derivative
where this x is involved
here here the mixed derivatives are
involved and here only y is involved
so these are fourth order derivatives
but in order to arrive at the fourth
order derivative we have to first start
with the first order derivative
so that is exactly what we have managed
to do here in the next page
so so just like f is a function of r and
theta
so also if you have the airy stress
function as
in the as a function of r and theta so
you can find out del phi del x
then uh proceeding uh by repeated use of
these kinds of chain rules
you can obtain del square phi del x
square
l cube phi del x x cube
del 4 phi del x 4 written in terms of
the corresponding
r and theta derivatives now of course
uh one may immediately start thinking
that this is going to be a terribly
laborious process
and it is so okay it is an extremely
extremely laborious time consuming
process
so we are not going to do it by hand
rather we are going to fall back
uh on outsourcing our labor to the
symbolic python
uh used in jupiter notebook okay so very
quickly
uh so what we'll do is we'll quickly
write down
these expressions for del r del x
del r del y del theta del x del theta
del
y and using just those things we can
very quickly build up
uh the derivatives the various order
derivatives
so that we can obtain the expression for
the laplacian and finally the
the by harmony uh in the polar
coordinate system so let's try to do
that
so we are now uh in in our browser here
i have already fired up jupiter notebook
and we are in our desired folder
i'm not going through the preliminary
steps which i have already demonstrated
in in the introductory videos so we'll
quickly
uh open a new
3 based jupyter notebook
this is our new file where we'll do all
our work
okay and as before our first job is to
import tempi as sim
that will take a little while hope it's
done uh
now the first thing we do is
we set up our variables the all
important variables r and theta
all right now uh you please note
that the that some of the things are
quite uh
i mean are very conveniently designed in
symbolic
uh python so suppose you want to
display the uh the theta variable which
is actually written in terms of
this th eta that's the name of the theta
variable
but if we run this thing you see the
actual visual representation of it
is actually in the symbol that you would
write in a piece of paper
okay so that's very nice all right
now as i mentioned our uh first job
would be to write down the expressions
of del r del x del r del y all these
things that we had written down
in our writing app here okay so going
back to the first page
so we'll write down this as del r del x
so del r del x let's check again this is
cos theta so
[Music]
that's done next del
r del y
we look at the expression again del r
del y is sine theta
so we use this
m dot sine theta next is del theta del x
we take a look again del theta del x
here
we have this as minus of sine theta by r
minus
and finally for del theta del y we have
let's check this del theta del y is cos
theta by r
all right so we have set up our
expressions
now next thing that we need to do is uh
define these uh these derivative
operators
so what i mean is if we go to the next
page on this writing app
we have set up this del f del x so these
are like
you can think of uh this left hand side
as the del del x operator operating on
f and correspondingly the
the expansion in terms of the r and
theta derivatives are like this
so that's what we are going to do we are
going to set up
a set these things up like operator
definitions in
in symbolic python so this is del f del
r del r del x
plus del f del theta delta del x okay
so what we really want is to use these
two expressions del r del x and del
theta del x
and we have to write down the operators
uh where we need to write down the
differentiation with respect to r
and the differentiation with respect to
theta okay so we can quickly do that
here
so we define a function which is like an
operative function here
we call this as it is completely our
choice but
uh in order uh for quick recognition
we'll just
give this kind of name
del del x of f okay please note
that i do not need to first uh
define a symbol or a function f here for
this definition because i am defining a
function
i mean this is this is very well
acceptable
so del del x of f is so i have to return
this thing
so given a certain f how do i return it
so
what i do is this is uh
i check the expression again so i need
the del r del x in this first term
i write that del r del x which is
already defined in this previous
input cell multiplied with the
del f del r so you see here we have the
del f del r
so that is basically just same
dot if f r
which means differentiate f with respect
to r
that's all there is to it in a similar
fashion for the second term
we use this del theta del x
del theta del x multiplied by
the derivative of f with respect to
theta and that's it
next in the same input cell we can set
setup or second operator definition
which is
del del y of f and for this we'll have
del
uh r del y times
same dot diff f comma r
plus del theta del y
times m dot if
f comma theta we check once again
this is perfectly all right here as you
can see del f del r
times del r del y plus del f del theta
times del theta del y okay so this is
done all right so our operator
definitions are done
now you see uh this is where
the real power of the computer algebra
system specifically symbolic python
is going to be used
if we were writing on a piece of paper
after this step we would have to
manually
find out the second order derivatives
that is del square
f del x square but we no longer have to
do that
because once we have already defined our
del del x operator all that you have to
do to find out the second order
derivative
is to make the operator operate on
itself so
we can just like we had defined this del
del x operator
we can define the second order
derivative like this we can call this
del
2 del x 2
okay this is completely my choice okay
this is certainly not part of the syntax
of
python this is my choice what i am
calling this operator
but i like this name so
here what i have to do is i have to use
this operator on itself so this is
basically del del
x operating on del del x
of f
okay
next for the
del square uh f del
y square i similarly uh define this
thing
absolutely same way using the del del y
operator that i had defined in the
previous cell
done now the moment i have this
the moment i have this i can
quickly go and uh quickly write down
my laplacian operator which is nothing
but the del square f del x
square plus del square f del y square
okay so since i have already defined
these second order derivatives
i can write down this uh this polar
laplacian okay so let's call this polar
laplacian
so again i'm defining it like a function
okay and all that i have to do is
just use what i have already done in the
previous cell so delta del x to f
plus del 2 del y to f
that's it okay see so easy
i'm building up step by step so first i
define the first order derivatives then
i define the second order derivatives
and using those definitions i can
quickly write down
the the definition of the polar
laplacian
okay so once we do this
uh let's actually see uh
how this is looking okay so till now we
have only defined these things
without really uh looking at
the the expressions okay uh
so let's set up
one function let's call this phi itself
okay
and let's set it up as a function of rm
theta
okay so that's that we have defined
that's where we have defined
the function let's just look at it okay
let's just
type in the name and to see
this is actually displaying phi but
because phi has been def
defined not as a symbol but as a
function
but this capital f is something internal
to symbolic python
capital f function is something uh
internal to symbolic python
you see that this functional dependence
on r and theta
is clearly displayed in this output cell
okay so we are good we can proceed to
find out
the polar laplacian of this okay so here
when i'm writing polar laplacian
i am depending on this input cell where
i have
already defined it myself so this polar
laplacian here that i am writing
it is not something internal to symbolic
python rather it is something which
i the user have defined okay
so here instead of this generic f which
was only used for the purpose of the
definition of the function
i am actually using this operator polar
laplacian
on the function that i have just now set
up
this file function okay and let us take
a look
if it even works
so it takes a little while and it gives
me this this huge expression
okay now if you look at these
expressions a little bit carefully you
will see that had you been
doing this by hand you would not have
gotten
this kind of a of a huge expression it
would have been
a little bit more simplified than this
because there are certain terms which
have not been cancelled
there are terms like sine squared theta
plus cos square theta
which because in the way that it has
been written in an
unexpanded fashion uh or a
non-simplified fashion
a symbolic python by default has not
been able to set equal to
one like terms like sine squared theta
plus cos by theta which
even in your sleep you can write as one
uh symbolic python has not been able to
do it
but we can help it a little bit uh in
its job
by going back to our definition of
or what we can do is before even going
back to the definition we can just see
if we can really help symbolic python
little bit by asking it to
additionally simplify this thing so we
just pass it past the past the extra
command like this
simplify
look at this how beautiful it has
simplified
okay and if you had done this by hand
you would not have been able to simplify
this
any further so this is the most
simplified font of the polar laplacian
now this we have done by additionally
topping up the polar laplacian operator
operating on phi
with this extra simplification or
simplify command
because we have done this why not more
wisely go back to the definition of the
polar laplacian itself
and embed the simplify command within
that
so that every time we invoke the polar
laplacian
operator we don't have to additionally
write this simplify
okay so whenever possible you try to
simplify
the expressions as as far as possible
this is not only for the purpose of
aesthetics okay not just to make it look
beautiful
rather uh for subsequent
calculations where you have to utilize
this polar laplacian
definition uh as part of your 2d
elasticity solutions
the uh it will it really helps symbolic
python to do the
further calculations okay so with that
motivation we are embedding
the simplify command in the definition
of the polar laplacian
and now if we come back to this cell
and delete this simplify command from
here
let us see if it gives us the same
result okay so previously it was giving
that
this and that on that really really long
expression of over
four five lines now we have embedded the
simplify command
in the in the definition so let's see if
this thing works
okay so it works very much okay even
without the simplify command here
it works so that's very good now the
moment we realize that this is very good
and it's working
what we can do is we can immediately go
and find out
the polar by harmonic okay because the
polar bear harmonic or the by harmonic
itself
the polar is just like in like uh
just a description to to explicitly
mention that we are working in the polar
coordinate system but this is the
laplacian okay
so for the pi harmonic all that you have
to do is to make the polar laplacian
operate on itself because del 4 you
realize
is nothing but del square operating on
del square okay
so let's uh let's define this polar bear
harmonic just like we had defined the
polar laplacian
just using this generic function f and
we return
okay we don't use any del 4 del x 4
anything like that we just use the polar
operating on itself polar laplacian
of the polar laplacian of
m that's it
now let's test this out
let's see what the polar bear harmonic
of
my five function which i have set up
what it looks like
now see if you were to
check these terms manually you will
realize
that there is no way to simplify this
further
okay i repeat there is no way to
simplify this further
and you realize that if you had to go
from this polar laplacian to this polar
by harmonic manually on hand
on a piece of writing on a piece of
paper how much labor you would have to
undergo
all of that is bypassed by by
outsourcing the algebra
to this uh to the symbolic python so
it's a big help
all right so
let us proceed now and
find out the the expressions of the
stresses
because i mean when you are doing a 2d
elasticity problem
your one of the primary interest would
be
not to stop at the solution of the by
harmonic equation
rather once you get the uh by harmonic
uh
or the eddy stress function in your hand
your interest one of the primary
interest would be to obtain the stress
fields and later on of course
to obtain the strain fields the
displacement fields
uh like that okay so
we know that uh sigma xx is
uh del square phi del
y square we can we can write that down
in even uh
so let's quickly remind ourselves
that we we already know that sigma xx is
equal to
l square phi del y square
sigma yy is equal to del square
phi del x square
and sigma x y is equal to minus
of del square pi del x del y
please note that all of these things are
written in the rectangular cartesian
coordinate system
but here we are we are what we are
trying to do
is obtain the corresponding forms in the
polar coordinate system
and since we have already defined the
del 2
del x 2 the del 2 del y 2 all these
things we have already done
so we can we believe
that it should be possible to obtain the
corresponding expressions of the sigma
xx sigma yy and sigma xy
but does that mean that our job is done
suppose you were to convert this del
square phi whatever this expression is
del square phi del y square
in terms of the derivatives involving
the r in theta does that mean that our
job
for our or our objective of finding the
stress fields
in the polar coordinate system is done
certainly not
because in the polar coordinate system
you note that sigma xx sigma yy and
sigma xy
is meaningless what you really need in
the polar coordinate system
is sigma r r sigma
theta theta and sigma r theta what are
these
well uh to to understand this
all that you have to uh to note is that
if you
if you're if you're really looking at
this x y coordinate system like this
so this is our x and this is our y
you can think of the r thick you i mean
you don't have to think of it like it
i mean it is what the r theta coordinate
system
is simply
like this
okay where this angle is theta this is
the
the r coordinate system this is the
theta one okay
uh you can think of it like unit vectors
e r hat and e theta hat all those things
but uh so so this is
an a a coordinate system which is
rotated from the x y coordinate system
by theta
and uh the moment you realize this sort
of a transformation or this sort of
relation geometric relation
between the between the orientations of
the r theta coordinate system
and the x y coordinate system you can go
back to the mathematical preliminaries
chapter
and use the the rotation tensor or the
rotation matrix
to obtain these things the sigma rr
sigma theta theta sigma r theta
from the sigma xx sigma yy and sigma xy
why
because you understand what you what we
are basically asking
is this that in the xy coordinate system
we have
the stresses in this fashion sigma xx so
this is the matrix representation of the
stress tensor
sigma x6 sigma xy and
sigma xy sigma yy
from this what we want
is again the stress tensor but in the r
theta coordinate system
where we have sigma r r sigma r theta
sigma sorry sigma r theta
sigma theta theta okay so in order to go
from here to here
all that you have to do is to use the
rotation matrices
appropriately okay so we have already
done that as part of our problem sheets
these kinds of second order
tensor transformations in our
mathematical preliminaries chapter and
we'll directly utilize those things here
okay so let's get back to the jupiter
notebook
so first of all our first job is to
convert
the sigma xx sigma yy and the sigma xy
those things in terms of the derivatives
of r and theta and further along we
will transform the stress matrix itself
in uh
from the sigma xx sigma xy and sigma yy
to the sigma r
sigma theta theta sigma r theta all
right so we have
uh quite a few jobs in our hand let's
let's address them one by one so uh
again we define this kind of sigma xx
all right now this is defined
just directly by using the del 2
so del 2 del y 2 okay
so let's not forget that the sigma x6
delta
2 del y2 of phi okay all right
for our generate definition this is just
f
all right similarly
sigma yy f is this
and finally
the sigma xy definition is this
del del x of del
del y of f you could equivalently write
this as
del del y of del del x of f it's the
same thing
okay you can check this yourself all
right so our definitions are done
so we can quickly check this okay so
sigma
xx of phi okay suppose phi is the
generic
uh edit stress function we do not know
its form right now
but let us say this is just a function i
mean we have set it up as a function of
r and theta
so what is the form of this sigma xx
so look at this the huge expression okay
and we'll see whether we can simplify
this or not later
okay uh right now we don't need to
display this thing so we
will cut it out rather what we'll do is
uh
let's just delete this cell escape
dt okay so that cell is deleted uh what
we'll do is
now we'll set up our stress matrix
using this sigma xx sigma yy and sigma
xy
so let's set this up because we are
working in the rectangular cartridge
coated system
i call this sigma direct of f
and what this will return is the matrix
form
okay the matrix form involving the sigma
xx of f sigma
xy of f in the first row and sigma
xy of f sigma
yy of f in the second row that's our
definition
okay i am not going to display this
because it's going to be a huge huge
thing
all i have to do now uh that i have
obtained this
matrix in the this stress matrix
in the rectangular cartesian coordinate
system i have to utilize
the uh the rotation tensor
to transform this to the r theta
coordinate system so that
from from that from that rectangular
from that
polar coordinate stress tensor i can
extract
my desired sigma rr sigma theta theta
and sigma
r theta okay so let me quickly go to the
writing app and remind ourselves
that the expression that we're looking
for is basically for the stress
transformation
okay for uh or the or the
stress
then said transformation
from the
rectangular cartesian coordinate system
to the polar coordinate system
what we use is
sigma so
this will be polar this will be equal to
this is my rotation matrix multiplied
by sigma but this sigma is written in
the rectangular cartesian coordinate
system
multiplied by q
transpose so q sigma rectangular
times q transpose so when we do this
thing
uh we'll end up with this this
tensor in the polar coordinate system so
what is this q
we have cos theta
sine theta minus sine theta
cos theta
so you can you can actually check this
by quickly going back to the diagram
that i had drawn earlier
and considering the
the angles that uh that this r
is making with the x and y so uh
the q one one term that is the first row
first column term that is the cos
of theta and the q 1 2 term
is the cos of 90 degree minus theta
which is a sine theta
and similarly for the second row uh we
have
we have this angle and this angle to
take care of
sorry this entire angle that theta makes
with this
x axis uh 90 degree uh
plus theta and this theta angle that
this theta makes with this
this theta axis makes with the y axis so
that's how we obtain the
minus sin theta and cos theta
so we can go back to
jupiter notebook and implement
this definition so q is
equal to
we need two rows here
so cos theta
sine theta minus
sine theta
cos theta
uh so you will notice that there is a
jump in the input sign
cell numbers here from 18 to 42 uh
that's because i've made some typing
mistakes in between
and i had to edit that out all right so
using this
q matrix we can now define the the sigma
polar
sigma polar is equal to
set it up like a definition as before
sigma polar of f
we return it ah so
this is the expression which we are
written up in our writing app
cube times sigma rectangle rectangular
of f times q dot t
so this q dot t is basically telling a
symbolic python to do the
transpose okay now
let's extract the sigma rr the sigma
theta theta and the sigma r theta
components out of this sigma polar
matrix so for that i'll again
set it up like function definitions
so this will be sigma polar i want
the element um
the setting in the first row and the
first column of sigma polar
and because uh python's index
indexing starts from zero we have to use
the zero comma zero for the first row in
the first column
okay next for sigma theta theta
uh please note that i am just writing
this in the short form as t t or theta
theta
this will be returned sigma polar
one comma one basically the second row
and the second column
and for sigma r theta
sigma product zero comma one okay
let's see what the sigma rr looks like
so i want to input within it
the phi
so sorry i've made a mistake here so
this is f
because uh the sigma the sigma polar in
the previous line has been
set up as a function definition
okay so we have this huge expression
coming out for sigma r
okay very huge expression uh so probably
if we ask
uh sim uh symbolic python to simplify
this
uh we get a shorter expression and as
you can expect
uh we have indeed come up with this
shorter expression but please note
that uh suppose you were writing this
on a piece of paper you would not have
stopped at this
rather you would have written this as 1
by r del del r of
pi plus 1 by r square del square phi del
theta square
so if we expand this out if you give the
further command to expand it
it will make it look it look much much
more
it will present in a much more familiar
form okay
not perfectly the way that you would
write in the on a piece of paper but
much closer to it okay so since we are
writing these
all these things here it will be better
if we just uh
embed this commands in the
in the function definition for sigma rr
itself
all right now let's see it immediately
gives us this nice simplified
looking expression next let's let's uh
let's check for the expression for sigma
theta
theta
and again you see it's such a huge
expression but probably if we simplify
this it will give us a much
shorter expression let's do that
and as you can see it's good and because
there's just one term here we don't even
have to expand it out
so we can just copy this simplify
command here
from here and put it and embed it in the
in the function definition for sigma
theta theta itself
okay done and now if you come back here
and re-implement it it should give us
the nice simplified expression directly
which it does
next let's uh let's check check for
sigma r theta
again this huge expression so probably
we need to simplify it
let's check that
and see nicely it is giving us this
thing and
maybe it's not a bad idea to expand it
out also so
let's do that
now uh as you must have noticed
that when i defined the sigma r theta i
used
the element in the first row and the
and the second column however
we expect that the sigma polar matrix
just like the
sigma rectangular matrix would be
symmetric so the theta r coordinate
that is the element sitting in the
second row first column
uh should be the same let's check that
suppose we define sigma tr of f
and we returned
the first row
a second row first column and let us not
forget to
issue the simplify and the expand
so that later on we don't have to do it
and the previous one also expand okay
so ideally our expectation is that sigma
rt should be equal to sigma tr that's
what we want to check
okay so we go back to this line delete
the
simplify and expand commands because we
have already embedded them in the
definition
and just check out the sigma tr
so we check this carefully they are
perfectly the same things
okay so at least the symmetry is very
much
satisfied now with these definitions in
hand
we are in a position to go on to the
solution of problems
involving the polar coordinate system
okay
now you may expect that
these definitions that we have written
down within this particular file
this will have to be uh
utilized over and over again in various
files
okay so whenever we set up a new file
for the solution
of a new problem in the polar coordinate
system
these basic definitions
where we have set up our polar laplacian
the polar bi-harmonic
and the various stress definitions these
will have to be set up
again and again okay and that's that can
be quite a tedious job like in every new
file if you have to do that
it's not very convenient so what we can
do is
we can collect all these definitions
which we have
we have which we have set up here and
we can put them nicely
in a separate file and we can invoke
those definitions as and when we need
in the separate uh in in every new file
that we that we use so let me
demonstrate that last
bit of actual uh actual use
very quickly so
so what we'll do is we will uh we'll set
up
a new file okay so let's go back to this
navigation
tab and you see back when we started our
when we started our new jupiter notebook
file we had clicked on this python three
now uh instead we can just click on this
text file
where we can put in the now so
so this text file will be initiated as a
text file but we can convert this to a
python file
okay that's what we'll do
okay so this is our uh
python file let me close this necessary
tab so
first of all you see that i had started
by this
thing so i'll just quickly copy paste
the various things in this
uh in this new file now what i can do is
i can
save this file
in this actually we rename this
as polar utilities
dot p y so this dot p y extension uh
makes the system understand that it is a
python file not a jupyter notebook
or an ipython notebook file rather it's
just it's a simple
python file okay
sorry uh there's a clash of the folders
because i'm currently currently in a
different folder
so i let me go back to our lectures
folder and here i will set it up
uh let me go back to the 2020
okay so let me close this one
let's set up a new file here
okay so
i rename this as uh
polar utilities.pi
and continue copying the various
lines into this as simple as that i just
copy this
here
and you'll see in a moment the the great
convenience this will afford us
as we as you open new files later on
so everything that we had defined uh
we are going to copy
please note that i don't need to copy
this pi
function okay because uh all my
definitions
are in terms of this genetic f function
so let it be like that
i also don't need to display these or to
copy these lines which were just for the
purpose of displaying
copy the polar bear harmonic
all the actually utilizable lines that i
copy
all the function definitions and
everything
you see we have defined quite a bunch of
functions
and this will be utilized again and
again
i'm almost done here
so you see i've skipped all those lines
where i just uh
utilized the function definitions to
display the various things
those i have not copied okay only the
things that i needed those i have
copied okay so uh
just save it now
let's say uh
let's see we close this file okay i have
saved it
i'll just just close this file
okay what i will do now
you see in back in my navigation tab
this was the untitled
uh file that i was working on okay
uh it is still running what i can do is
i can just shut it down
okay it does not mean that it is deleted
it's just it's
gone inactive now now what i will do is
i will
open up a fresh file okay i'll just open
up a fresh file
refresh jupyter notebook file
so you see back in my navigation tab
this has gone to the green color this
untitled one
this untitled one is this is this new
file that i have opened
okay so uh
let's rename this okay just rename this
instead of untitled one something
meaningful uh
maybe let's call this polar
polar demo 2 okay
i'll go back and name this untitled
file as polar demo one
okay so let me get back to polar demo
two so you see i have not
imported senpai or anything here however
what i will do is
i am going to import this polar
utilities
okay and the way that i am going to
import it
is just like a just like the uh
import of the general way that
packages are imported so from polar
utilities
i am going to import everything
now earlier when we were importing
symbolic python
we had imported as input sempi
as sim we might as well have
imported that as from sempi
import star this import star basically
means
that i am importing everything that is
within that package
symbolic python okay
into the current file so that's exactly
what i want to do here
now this kind of a command from
any generic package uh import everything
this is not exactly encouraged in the
python community nowadays
okay so despite that i'm doing it here
that's uh because uh this is a very very
small package where something
and this is completely under my control
i know what i have defined here there is
no problem
and the good thing is within it i have
imported
the same pie as it should be as it is
actually encouraged in the python
community
okay so the main reason that it is
it is suggested that we import it like
this is that
if within the same pipe package there is
something
there is some function or some variable
which probably clashes with another
package
and there is a lot of clash with the
numpy package the numerical python
package
uh so there will they won't be any clash
if we just
prepend the function names like this sim
dot
cos theta or something like that okay
otherwise they may be a clash
uh or at least some sort of confusion
will arise
but at least for our current case there
is no confusion like that
so we get we are safe to do it let me
just
do this kind of a input you see it it
imported without any error
now the good thing is even though
currently in this
polar demo 2 file i have not imported
symbolic python rather i have imported
the
polar utilities let's see this
polarities file
within which the import of symbolic
python has been done
and whatever else has been defined here
that is currently available
uh here okay and i can check that out so
suppose
i uh so see here i have also not defined
the r
theta but suppose i write theta okay
like if you
if you had to open a new file and just
write theta it's going to give you an
undefined
error or something like that okay now
you see
it understands because at the background
all this importing has already been done
from this polar utilities python which
we have in which we have written all the
other utilizable things so
what we can do is we can set up this
generic function phi
sorry i which is
dependent on r and theta and now let's
say we want to display this sigma r i
okay see in this entire file in this
entire file nothing like
just two lines have have been written
here okay and these are just
i mean it has nothing to do with the
sigma rr but based on what we have
imported in this first line
i'll be able to directly use it so if i
write sigma r at 5 it should
actually give me the answer
you see similarly for sigma t
so you see the great convenience this
supports us
this polar utilities file as long as it
is there in the current folder
it should be you should be able to
import it
like in this first line here and then
continue with your actual uh solution of
the
problem so with this i end this part of
the rather long
uh lecture
and we'll continue with the with actual
solutions of problems in polar
coordinate system
from the next one all right thank you
very much